hey everyone we have an exciting topic
for today this video will walk you
through the top
five highest paying jobs for the year
2021
the list in this video can help you plan
for your career in 2021 at number five
we have a role of a big
data engineer big data has been a
revolution in every business sector over
the last 10 years
big data engineers store process and
analyze data
they develop design test and maintain
the big data architecture in an
organization
they should have in-depth knowledge of
hadoop spark rdbms
and nosql they should have hands-on
experience with languages such as java
and python
and they need to know tools like hive
and pig they must also possess
data warehousing skills companies like
ernst and young
robert half mastercard and amazon hire
big data engineers big data engineers
earn 300
000 dollars in the united states and in
india nearly 30 lakh rupees per annum
next at number four we have full
stack developer a full stack developer
works with both the front and back ends
of a website
they tackle projects that involve
building user facing websites and work
with clients during the planning phase
of a project to become a full stack
developer you must know
html and css you should also be
proficient in javascript and its
frameworks
you need to be familiar with server side
languages like ruby
php python and net finally you must know
how to work with mysql
oracle and mongodb fedex dell equifax
and accenture actively hire full stack
developers
full stack developers in the us earn
nearly 226 thousand dollars and in india
about 35 lakh rupees per annum at number
three we have
cloud architect a cloud architect is an
information technology expert
who supervises an organization's cloud
computing system
and works on cloud application designs
cloud architects work with devops
engineers and developers
to ensure that the right technology is
being built they should know cloud
computing technologies like aws
azure and gcp they should be proficient
in programming languages like java
python and c-sharp they must know tools
such as kubernetes
and docker companies like huawei amazon
web services
unisys and medtronic hire cloud
architects in the us
an experienced cloud architect can earn
nearly 240
000 and in india anywhere between 16 to
50
lakh rupees per annum moving on at
number two we have product manager
product managers are responsible for the
product development for an organization
they guide the success of a product and
supervise its improvement
they are the brains behind the business
strategies of a product
product managers must be strategic
thinkers they should understand data
business competencies and market trends
they must be technically sound with
respect to their industry wells fargo
oracle hitachi and apple hire product
managers
in the u.s product managers earn up to
250 000
and in india as high as one crore rupees
per annum
finally let's look at which job role we
have at number one and that is the role
of a data
scientist a data scientist is a
professional who makes use of different
statistical methods
data analysis techniques and machine
learning to comprehend and analyze data
to arrive at crucial business
conclusions
a data scientist should be proficient in
microsoft excel
sql and no programming languages like
python r
and java they should be good at machine
learning and deep learning concepts
familiarity with apache hive
pig and spark is also necessary
companies hiring for data scientists
include shell
facebook haliburton and google a data
scientist with a fair amount of
experience earns
up to eight hundred thousand dollars in
the us
and in india nearly 60 lakh rupees per
annum
and there you go those are the top five
highest paying jobs in 2021
with that we've reached the end of this
video do you agree with our top 10 list
will data scientists still be in the
sexiest job of 21st century
let us know in the comments thank you
for watching this video and stay tuned
for more from simply learn